-This is our third show
back in the studio,
and my third show surrounded
by actual human beings
which is great because it means
I no longer need
to talk to inanimate objects
like I did when I was in my
attic or the captain's quarters.
-Hey, Seth.
-Oh, no!
You got the Prock doll
from the animated series,
"The Awesomes," that I voiced?
You can talk, too?
-Yeah, I can.
And I've been in touch
with the sea captain.
-Uh-huh.
-He wanted me to ask you
a question.
-Is it a real question,
or like a dumb sea-based pun?
-What did
the mythical sea creature say
when he got to the party?
-Uh, I don't know.
-What's "crackin'"? [Kraken]
[ Laughter ]
"Awesomes," all three seasons
available to stream on Hulu.
-I want everyone here to stop
talking to the sea Captain.
He's a bad influence, and
speaking of bad influences...
-Uh-hah! Awesome segue, Seth!
-Thank you, microphone.
The president confessed on tape
that he knew about the severity
of the coronavirus pandemic
and lied to the American people.
And you'll never guess how
Republicans are reacting --
they're pretending
they haven't heard about it.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Obviously
it's hard to keep track
of all the grotesque criminality
and sociopathic incompetence
of the Trump administration
on any given day.
It's like trying to follow all
the timelines on "Westworld."
I thought that was the past?
No, that was the future.
And I thought that guy
was a human?
No, he's a robot. He just
got out of his milk bath.
Just in the last 24 hours,
we've learned that Trump's
Department of Homeland Security
censored intelligence on Russian
meddling in the 2020 election,
downplayed the threat
of white supremacist terrorism,
and distorted evidence to match
Trump's lies about antifa,
the health department
tried to muzzle the government's
top infectious disease expert
and prevent him from warning
the public about the dangers
coronavirus poses to children,
and on top of all that,
the president admitted on tape
months ago that he knew
the coronavirus was deadly
and airborne and confessed
that he was lying
when he downplayed the threat
of a dangerous
and highly infectious disease.
Or as Fox News put it...
-Good evening, everybody.
President Trump today
had a great day --
a day that any president
could only dream of.
-Oh, hey, look, everybody,
it's Baghdad Blob.
I've heard of brown nosing,
but apparently,
Dobbs is in there so deep,
his hair turned brown.
Normally when an old man
says something like that,
you have to tell him,
"Grandpa, Harry Truman is dead!"
But, hey, if I'm gonna believe
anyone, it's the guy
who combs his hair like
a 5-year-old at a wedding.
[ As Lou Dobbs ]
I'm a big boy, mommy,
and you can trust me
to hold the rings.
[ Normal voice ] These guys
are all such creepy weirdos.
They're like Stepford pundits.
Dobbs talks like a guy
who just got through
with six hours
of electroshock therapy.
But even the Fox News reality
distortion machine couldn't hide
the damning truth because it was
in the president's own words.
Let's just remember, this is
what Trump was saying publicly
as a deadly virus
was spreading across the world
and threatening
Americans' lives.
-It's going to disappear.
One day, it's like a miracle.
It will disappear.
The virus, they're working hard.
Looks like by April,
you know, in theory,
when it gets a little warmer,
it miraculously goes away.
I hope that's true.
Now, the virus that we're
talking about having to do --
you know, a lot of people think
that goes away in April with
the heat, as the heat comes in.
Typically,
that will go away in April.
China is very professionally run
in the sense
that they have everything
under control.
I really believe they are
going to have it
under control fairly soon.
You know, in April, supposedly,
it dies with the hotter weather.
And that's a beautiful date
to look forward to.
We're working very strongly
with China on the coronavirus.
That's a new thing that a lot
of people are talking about.
-"That's a new thing that a lot
of people are talking about."
And by the way, you don't
look like the guy I go to
to find out the new thing
everyone's talking about.
You look like the guy I go to
when I'm confused about
the condo by-laws.
Talks about a deadly disease
like it's a new app.
[ As Trump ] It's a new thing
a lot of people are talk--
It's called FaceApp.
I tried it,
but it just gave me
the "Ark of the Covenant" face.
[ Normal voice ] Also, among
other things about that montage,
he also said it would get hot
in April.
So I guess he really is
a Floridian now.
"It gets pretty hot in April,
and I tell ya,
it makes you long for those
Christmastime swamp mists."
It's like how when you call
your grandparents in Palm Beach
and they complain that it's
freezing 'cause it's 68 degrees.
"Your grandfather's
out chopping firewood,
and I'm putting antifreeze
in the golf cart."
Also, why do you think
the heat would cure it?
Are you running a government
or a sweat lodge?
Sounds like one of those
over-tan weirdos at the gym
who thinks the sauna
is a cure-all for everything.
"Your back hurts? Just hit
the sauna for a few hours.
All that heat
helps soften your bones.
[ Chuckling ]
And, uh, towel is optional."
Now, the question with Trump
is always,
"Is he deluded or is he lying?"
Obviously, the answer
is often both,
but in this particular case,
it turns out Trump
wasn't just in denial.
He did know the truth
about the coronavirus,
and he lied about it.
He was aware that it was
airborne, that it was deadly,
and that it was worse
than the flu.
He could have easily informed
the American people
of the risks.
Instead, he covered it up --
as he confessed to journalist
Bob Woodward
in the bombshell tapes.
-Indeed it is.
-I think one of the most
shocking things about that tape
is hearing Trump talk even
semi-coherently about something.
Someone get
"Flowers for Algernon."
Seriously, that's the same guy
who publicly suggested
injecting bleach
and told everyone heat would
make the virus go away.
On tape, he almost sounds like
he knows what he's
talking about.
[ As Trump ] You know, Bob,
they conducted
a double blind study,
and it turns out aerosolized
transmission
is a much more significant
vector than fomites,
contributing to an increased
case fatality ratio.
Anyway, I gotta go, Bob.
Doing a press conference
announcing
that battery acid
cures hemorrhoids.
[ Normal voice ]
Imagine if Trump had said
what you just heard on that tape
in public
at the start of the outbreak.
Even if he'd screwed up
everything else,
which he definitely would have,
it still would have helped
encourage more of his supporters
to take the virus seriously.
Instead, while he was
privately confessing
that he knew coronavirus
was much deadlier than the flu,
he was publicly telling people
it was just like the flu
and suggesting it could even
be cured by a flu shot.
-That's a little bit like
the flu.
It's a little like the regular
flu that we have flu shots for.
And we'll essentially have
a flu shot for this
in a fairly quick manner.
A lot of people will have this,
and it is very mild.
They will get better
very rapidly.
They don't even see a doctor.
They don't even call a doctor.
You never hear about those
people,
so you can't put them down
in the category
of the overall population
in terms of this corona flu
or virus.
You take a solid flu vaccine.
You don't think that would have
an impact
or much of an impact on corona?
-[ Chuckling ] It's such
a bummer that Trump
is surrounded by yes men,
because as evidenced
by that clip, he immediately
backs down on the rare occasions
when he hears no.
[ As Trump ] Maybe the flu
vaccine would work?
[ Normal voice ] No.
[ As Trump ] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because it's separate.
'Cause it's two separate things.
I was just testing you.
Knew that, as well.
[ Normal voice ] And if you're
still wondering if this was
an intentional strategy to hide
the true danger of the situation
from the American people,
it was,
because Trump confessed to that,
too.
-Oh, you didn't want
to create a panic?
Well, congrats, dude,
you nailed it.
For the last six months,
I did my show
from literally a panic room.
Aside from a once-in-a-century
economic crash
that's threatened
the health and livelihoods
of millions of people, not
to mention lines at food banks
and fights in supermarket aisles
over toilet paper,
everybody is super chill.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I have to go wash my face mask
and microwave my mail.
Seriously, I thought after
four years of Trump
confessing to galling crimes,
I'd lost my capacity to be
shocked, but this one got me.
I was mostly shocked that he was
dumb enough to confess something
so cartoonishly evil to a
reporter who was recording him.
It's like if the Unabomber
had put a return address
on all of his packages.
Trump claimed he was just trying
to be prudent by withholding
the truth about
a deadly disease,
a talking point
that has been parroted
by his toadies on Fox News.
-Well, I think, if you said
in order to reduce panic,
perhaps that's so.
The fact is, I'm
a cheerleader for this country.
I love our country.
And I don't want people
to be frightened.
I don't want to create panic,
as you say.
And certainly I'm not
going to drive this country
or the world into a frenzy.
-President's job is to
maintain order
and, by the way, right the ship
during and after a crisis,
not spread panic, not spreading
fear among the population.
-He didn't want people to
freak out,
so he tried to keep people calm.
-Oh, yeah, totally. Trump is
the picture of calm and poise.
He's spent the last four years
claiming caravans of migrants
were coming to kill everyone
and airplanes full of mysterious
black-clad thugs
were flying cross country
to burn down cities.
He's the human embodiment
of yelling "Fire!"
in a crowded theater.
Of course, nowadays,
you can cause a panic
by yelling "Crowded theater!"
He panics more than an uptight
Greenwich matriarch
who finds out her daughter
is dating a tattooed biker.
He's going to ruin our
reputation at the country club!
By the way,
dibs on that screenplay.
I will have you know this urn
holds my grandfather's ashes,
and would appreciate
if you stop calling it janky!
Okay. Pretty janky urn, though.
[ Chuckles ]
And can we please
go back to this?
-Well, I think if you said
"in order to reduce panic,"
perhaps that's so.
-Oh, perhaps that's so?
I'm so [bleep] sick
of watching this guy
try out every excuse
until one sticks.
You just know Trump's the kind
of guy who takes one bite
of every chocolate in the box.
[ As Trump ] Excuse me. Are any
of these filled with gravy?
Also, the choices aren't
"lie or panic."
There's a third option where you
tell people the truth
and then do something about it,
which would reassure everyone.
But, no, we elected the guy
who puts a piece of duct tape
over the check engine light.
A Trump brand fire alarm
wouldn't beep.
It would just tell you that,
in April, it rains a lot,
and that should
put out the fire.
Even after the tapes came out,
Republicans
did their usual routine
of ducking into elevators,
hiding behind potted plants,
and claiming they haven't
read the book,
even though the comments
are on tape
and on every TV and website
everywhere.
And even when they were
confronted on TV,
like Louisiana Senator
John Kennedy,
they short-circuited.
-These gotcha books don't really
interest me that much.
-He's on the record.
He's on the record.
-These gotcha books don't
really interest me that much.
There will be a new one out
tomorrow.
-But this is different.
He did 18 interviews
with Bob Woodward.
-Right.
-He's recorded.
You hear his voice.
And you're seeing that and
you're contrasting that
with what he says to the public.
Wouldn't that be something
of interest to you
as a United States senator?
-Well, let me answer you again.
These gotcha books
don't really interest me.
-Uh-oh, someone take
John Kennedy to the shop.
There's smoke
coming out of his ears.
We're gonna need to open
this bad boy up
and check out the wiring.
And if you're too busy
for gotcha books,
you should try gotcha books
on tape.
The president made you one.
Also, I'm not going to
take advice on reading
from a guy who sounds like
drunk Huckleberry Hound.
He sounds like his home address
definitely contains the word
"yonder."
with that said, he might not
have been the one repeating
himself.
It could have been the bullfrog
stuck in his throat.
Also, maybe you should be less
concerned about gotcha books
and more concerned that your
president is so easy to get.
I mean, he's the dope who agreed
to talk to Bob Woodward,
of all people, who is famous
for "gotcha"
on a presidential level.
Why did Trump think
it wouldn't end like this?
Are you sure you want to do
these interviews, Mr. President?
[ As Trump ]
Oh, yeah, Woodward's safe.
He already used his "gotcha"
on Nixon.
[ Normal voice ] In the Trump
era, we're constantly bombarded
with scandal, so everything
feels ephemeral,
but this -- this should stick.
You can't dismiss this as some
esoteric DC obsession
or some insider gossip.
Nearly 200,000 of our fellow
Americans have died,
millions more have suffered,
the president and everyone
around him
knew that would happen.
They did nothing.
And they lied about it.
In a just world,
in a functioning democracy,
all of these people
would be shamed
and banished from power
for good.
At the very least, they should
lose their jobs in November,
which would be...
-A beautiful date
to look forward to.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪